un exercice plus difficile qu'il n'y
paraît ces jarres sont construites
d'après un savoir-faire africains les
dix élèves du cours céramiques poteries
du conservatoire des arts de montigny le
bretonneux font découvrir leurs
techniques les gros boudin qui sont
posés les uns sur les autres et qui sont
après est tiré voilà pour être plus fins
et une technique assez rapide et c'est
vrai qu'en afrique on a une chaleur qui
permet de pouvoir monter assez
rapidement nous ici on a une hydrométrie
et une température qui qui varie suivant
les cuissons suivant le temps donc on
est obligé de le faire évoluer lentement
mais c'est une technique qui permet pas
de grandes jarres la terre quand on n'y
touche c'est c'est comme une vibration
dans tout le corps
c'est vrai on met lass et c'est une
terre gré chamottée qui abîment un peu
les doigts
présent au coeur de l'exposition les
visiteurs pourront les rencontrer tous
les mardis peinture volume met à
l'honneur les artistes de demain nous
inspirons d'une oeuvre
d'un photographe hollandaise daniel van
zadelhoff qui travaille beaucoup sur les
clairs obscurs et donc j'ai pris ce
travail comme exemple c'est pour une pop
une forme de deux confirmations et
d'encouragement par rapport à ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire est de mettre en
pratique un peu ce qu'ils apprennent
rigueur créativité et détermination des
qualités que chacun peut développer lors
des cours du conservatoire des arts
les inscriptions sont ouvertes à tous